welcome back dr nash and total
transformation the sponsors of this next
segment have been changing lives all
across the valley and today we take a
look at a few of her client success
stories
dr nash it is always great to have you
on the show and i'm super excited
because today we're talking about
success stories and we're starting off
with one of the most important success
stories and that is yours 80 pounds over
13 years ago how'd you do it how did you
keep it all so i struggled with obesity
for more than 25 years of my life from
the time i was eight years old diet
after diet that i would try my body
would either lose weight slowly or not
at all and it always gained it back it
was so frustrating but when i found out
that there was damage inside my body
that was actually driving the weight
problem not so much how much i was
eating and moving that's when i focused
on correcting the damage that's when the
80 pounds came off and spun off ever
since you look beautiful the results are
amazing let's start off here with let's
start with catherine i went from a size
14 to a size 6 in 30 days i no longer
suffer from fibromyalgia and i no longer
suffer from depression i love
catherine's results because there's the
physical results and then there's the
mental results that the issue she had
with depression has gone away after
working with you yeah so we can really
relate to cj cj had a death in the
family that hit her pretty hard and she
gained a lot of weight afterwards from
the grieving process and then it just
wouldn't come back off and this is
because some damage in the metabolism
had occurred we corrected it she goes
from a 14 to a six in 30 days left my
program went on to be a size four and
has been holding it ever since now we
have to go to my guy dominic everybody
take a look at dominic working with dr
nash i lost 70 pounds in three and a
half months and reversed my type 2
diabetes and i feel great almost a
hundred pounds for dominic and he says
something there in the beginning working
with dr nash because you're with your
clients and your patients the entire
time correct i am and he's somebody that
was diagnosed with pre-diabetes when he
was only 20 years old and tried to fix
it himself for five years and nothing
happened so that's why he says working
with dr nash when he hit 25 it turned
into full-fledged diabetes but we were
able to reverse it in three and a half
months
amazing amazing okay let's go to sarah
here is sarah in just three short months
of losing weight i've lost 52 pounds and
35 inches off my waist which is where i
wanted it most
52 pounds
mind blown with the stuff that you do
for your patients tell me more about
sarah's story so sarah's story is i'm
sure relatable to a lot of women where
they're just busy all the time she had a
full-time job she was going to nursing
school she was taking care of a disabled
husband and two children she did not
have time to devote to hours and hours
of eating less and moving more we
corrected the metabolic damage not only
did she lose that 52 pounds but 35
inches around the midsection alone jc
that's crazy can every week dr nash you
bring a special what do you got this
week of course so normally to be able to
talk to me and do that one-on-one
evaluation so i can determine what the
problem is with you that's normally 97
but of course when people say that they
saw me with jc on las vegas now i'm
going to do something special come on
man so we're going to do 10 spots at
9.97 for that evaluation 90 off the
price you just have to go to the website
in order to make it happen but do it
fast because these sell out quickly
thank you again to total transformation
for sponsoring this segment in las vegas
now we will be right